a lazy afternoon in a futon one of
Beijing's traditional residential alleys
in the heart of the city this is back
Street Beijing it smells of fresh
vegetables seafood and pastry people
here have to earn their houses into
small shops and eateries for years these
restaurants and kiosks have attracted
not only locals but also an
international crowd but recently the
residents have received unwelcome guests
notices like these have said the end of
busy shopping and eating alleys the
government is taking action against
building work that has been done without
the proper license and that's hitting
those little shops and restaurants in
the alleys traditionally these houses
are open on to the courtyards and our
wall towards the streets new outward
windows and doors are unlicensed illegal
the city governments and workers to
brick them you need to be quick if you
want to use them
your days on LMFAO - Oh robot that the
shop has helped us make some money to
improve our lives so of course we don't
like this decision but what can we do if
the government says so we have to obey
Authority x' have declined to comment on
this issue more than 1000 alleys are
under threat shop owners they are stand
to lose their livelihoods for me it's
tough I'm selling almost nothing
recently I think I have no other choice
then go back to my home province for the
moment she and her neighbors do their
best to keep their shops open and
finding creative ways to avoid standing
on a stool by a tiny window all day